Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，因为 Eglinton Crosstown 轻轨列车正在进行测试。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic, award-winning vehicle has been redefined with a distinctive, modern design. A reimagined exterior features compelling proportions and precise detailing. Built with integrity and purpose, the interior boasts robust, durable materials. Whether it's the all-terrain capability, ample cargo capacity, or innovative camera technology, the Defender 110 lets you go further and do more. And with seating for up to seven, everyone can enjoy the journey.
请保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。对于那些拥抱不可能的人来说，卫士 110（Defender 110）已准备好迎接冒险。这款标志性且屡获殊荣的车型以独特、现代的设计进行了重新定义。重新构想的外观具有引人注目的比例和精确的细节。内饰秉承诚信与宗旨，采用了坚固耐用的材料。无论是全地形能力、充足的载货空间，还是创新的摄像头技术，卫士 110 都能让您走得更远，做得更多。此外，它最多可容纳七人，让每个人都能享受旅程。
Learn more at LandRover.ca A shipload of worry for Mr. George Isaacs, Minister of Labour, will arrive at Tilbury on Saturday week. 500 West Indians, all seeking jobs in Britain. Mr Isaacs confessed his worry to MPs yesterday. He said he does not know who sent the men. All I know, he added, is that they are in a ship and are coming here. They are British citizens and we shall do our best for them when they arrive. But MPs did not allow the mystery of 500 British citizens to rest there. Mr Dryberg, Malden Essex, asked, Will you instruct your officials to meet the ship and
了解更多信息请访问 LandRover.ca。下周六，一船让劳工大臣乔治·艾萨克斯（George Isaacs）先生忧心忡忡的乘客将抵达蒂尔伯里（Tilbury）。500 名西印度群岛人，都在英国寻找工作。艾萨克斯先生昨天向议员们坦承了他的担忧。他说他不知道是谁派这些人来的。他补充说，我只知道他们在一艘船上，正往这里来。他们是英国公民，等他们抵达时，我们会尽力为他们提供帮助。但议员们并没有让这 500 名英国公民的谜团就此平息。埃塞克斯郡马尔登（Malden, Essex）的德赖伯格（Dryberg）先生问道，你会指示你的官员去迎接这艘船并
help them find work in undermanned industries in the interests of production and welfare? Mr Isaacs answered, They will be met at the ship and told how to register for unemployment. The arrival of these substantial numbers of men under no organised arrangements is bound to result in difficulty and disappointment. I have no knowledge of their qualifications or capacity and can give no assurance that they can be found suitable work. I hope no encouragement will be given to others to follow them. So that, Dominic, was from the Daily Express on the 8th of June, 1948, reporting on the response
为了生产和福利，帮助他们在人手不足的行业找到工作吗？艾萨克斯先生回答说，他们将在船上被迎接，并被告知如何登记失业。在没有任何组织安排的情况下，如此大量的人员抵达必然会导致困难和失望。我不知道他们的资格或能力，也无法保证能为他们找到合适的工作。我希望不要鼓励其他人效仿他们。所以，多米尼克，那段话摘自 1948 年 6 月 8 日的《每日快报》，报道了
in the House of Commons to the arrival at Tilbury of the Empire Windrush, a ship that now is probably as famous in British history as the Mary Rose or HMS Victory. And it's become a kind of foundational moment, hasn't it, in 20th and 21st century British history? It absolutely has, Tom. First of all, I should say to all our listeners, it's lovely to finally discover how Daily Express journalists in the late 1940s spoke, courtesy of that wonderful, wonderful impersonation. Okay. Well, it's kind of a Pathé-Daily Express crossover.
下议院对“帝国疾风号”（Empire Windrush）抵达蒂尔伯里的反应，这艘船现在在英国历史上可能和玛丽玫瑰号（Mary Rose）或胜利号（HMS Victory）一样出名。它已经成为 20 世纪和 21 世纪英国历史上的一个奠基性时刻，不是吗？确实如此，汤姆。首先，我应该对我们所有的听众说，很高兴终于能通过那段精彩绝伦的模仿，了解到 20 世纪 40 年代末《每日快报》的记者们是如何说话的。好吧，这算是一种百代新闻（Pathé）与《每日快报》的跨界结合。
It was. But you're absolutely right, Tom. So the Windrush has become, dare I say, to use one of your favourite words, it's become kind of sacralised, hasn't it? It is this sacred moment in the history of British multiculturalism, immigration, race relations, and so on and so forth. But the story behind the Windrush is itself a very complicated and fascinating story. And then actually the wider story is more variegated i would say more complicated and multi-layered than most people i think now recognize so the trouble is now this story of multiculturalism and immigration which are not the same thing of course but this story has become freighted hasn't it with so much kind of political and moral you know, that it's very hard to talk about it as a historian. Do you not think?
确实是。但你说得完全对，汤姆。所以“疾风号”已经变得——我敢说，用你最喜欢的词之一——它已经变得某种程度上被“神圣化”了，不是吗？它是英国多元文化主义、移民、种族关系等历史上的一个神圣时刻。但“疾风号”背后的故事本身就是一个非常复杂且引人入胜的故事。而且实际上，更广泛的故事比我认为现在大多数人所认识到的要更加多样化，我会说更加复杂和多层次。所以现在的问题是，这个关于多元文化主义和移民的故事——当然它们不是一回事——已经承载了太多的政治和道德色彩，以至于作为历史学家很难去谈论它。你不觉得吗？
Well, we are about to find out because we have the perfect guest to hold our hands and lead us through some of the 75 years that have passed since the Windrush arrived. And that is Trevor Phillips, of course, founder of the Equality and Human Rights Commission and columnist and author with his brother, Mike, of a book called Windrush, which Trevor, I think came out in the 90s, didn't it? But it's been reissued now and updated. Brilliant account, not just of Windrush itself, but of the history of West Indian settlement in Britain and the years that have followed that. And also, I think, really importantly, what you were talking about, Dominic, the kind of the mythic
好吧，我们马上就会知道答案，因为我们有一位完美的嘉宾来引导我们走过“疾风号”抵达后的 75 年。他就是特雷弗·菲利普斯（Trevor Phillips），平等与人权委员会的创始人，也是专栏作家，并与他的兄弟迈克合著了一本名为《疾风号》（Windrush）的书。特雷弗，我想这本书是在 90 年代出版的，对吧？但现在已经再版并更新了。这是一部精彩的著作，不仅讲述了“疾风号”本身，还讲述了西印度群岛人在英国的定居史以及随后的岁月。而且，我认为非常重要的一点是，多米尼克你刚才提到的，整个故事所呈现的那种神话般的
character that the whole story has come to take on. So Trevor, thanks so much for coming on The Rest Is History. Would you recognise what Dominic said, that it's become a sacralised story? Yes. Thank you, Dominic. Thank you, Tom, for having me on. As far as I understand, the use of the word cyclised here, I think that's right. It's probably worth starting by saying that your use of word myth here is correct. As we say, I think in the introduction to the book, the original introduction to the book, we could have chosen several other boats that brought people from the Caribbean, because the Windrush wasn't the only one. It was probably one of the larger groups,
特质。所以特雷弗，非常感谢你来到《历史的余味》。你认同多米尼克所说的它已经变成了一个被神圣化的故事吗？是的。谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢你，汤姆，邀请我参加节目。据我理解，这里使用“神圣化”这个词，我认为是恰当的。首先值得一提的是，你在这里使用“神话”这个词是正确的。正如我们在书的引言，即最初的引言中所说，我们本可以选择其他几艘从加勒比海运送人员的船只，因为“疾风号”并不是唯一的一艘。它可能是规模较大的群体之一，
nearly 500 men and women, but it wasn't alone. What I think was striking about it, to be honest, is that, this is a kind of meta story, I suppose, it was one of the first of these kinds of events to be immortalised on film and to have that sort of Alva Liddell voice crystallising it for history, historians to pour over and to analyse and so on. So we chose the Windrush when we decided to do this,
近 500 名男女，但它并不孤单。老实说，我认为它引人注目的是，这是一种元叙事，我想，它是最早被电影永恒化，并拥有那种阿尔瓦·利德尔（Alva Liddell）式的声音为历史定格，供历史学家去研读和分析的事件之一。所以当我们决定做这件事时，我们选择了“疾风号”，
not just because of the fact that it was mentioned in Parliament and so on, but because, frankly, there's a lot of evidence. We could tell who the people were, and we could talk to some of them. When we wrote the book in 1998, it was still possible to meet these men and women and to talk to them and interview them directly. Now there are only two of them who survive so the origins of this book which is in itself an origin story are a mixture I suppose of my own desire to tell a story about who my family is because I think at that time we were still sort of slightly two-dimensional characters you know basically people who smoked dope and got into trouble with the police and that was it at that time, we were still sort of slightly two-dimensional characters, you know, basically people who smoked dope and got into trouble with the police and that was it. And with no history
不仅仅是因为它在议会中被提及等等，而是因为，坦率地说，有大量的证据。我们可以确定这些人是谁，并且可以与他们中的一些人交谈。当我们在 1998 年写这本书时，还有可能见到这些男女并与他们交谈，直接采访他们。现在他们中只有两人健在。所以这本书的起源——它本身就是一个起源故事——我想是我个人想要讲述关于我家庭是谁的故事的混合体，因为我认为在那个时候，我们仍然是稍微有点二维的人物，你知道，基本上就是那些吸毒、惹上警察麻烦的人，当时就是这样。而且没有历史
whatsoever, I think if I'm honest, part of my motivation for promoting what was originally thought of as a documentary for television, but became a book as well, was irritation at the fact that every time I walked into a room or anytime I met somebody, they would see me as a person with no story of my own, no narrative, other than what other people had done to me and my community. And the important thing for me about Windrush was that we wanted to tell a story that explained some of who we are. By the way, Tom, I mean, you could do this for a living, that impersonation. Thanks very much.
可言。如果我诚实地说，我推动这个最初被认为是电视纪录片，但后来也变成了书的项目，部分动机是因为我感到恼火：每次我走进一个房间或遇到某人时，他们都会把我视为一个没有自己故事、没有叙事的人，除了别人对我及我的社区所做的事情之外。对我来说，“疾风号”的重要之处在于，我们想讲述一个能解释我们是谁的故事。顺便说一句，汤姆，我是说，你可以靠这个为生，那段模仿。非常感谢。
The striking thing I think about that moment was, in a way, it's part of these islands' history, isn't it? Boats always being trouble. Whether it's Vikings or more latterly, people coming across the channel. The English are always worried about boats turning up. But they also bring new beginnings. So whether it's Julius Caesar landing or actually more germainly, the Anglo-Saxons, you know, Hengist and Horsa landing at Thanet. I mean, it is a narrative of invasion, but it's also a narrative of new beginnings and new opportunities. So, I mean, that is such a fascinating point. I think we should kind of look at that perhaps towards the end of the show when we're looking at how the resonance that the Windrush has.
我认为那个时刻最引人注目的是，在某种程度上，它是这些岛屿历史的一部分，不是吗？船只总是带来麻烦。无论是维京人，还是最近穿过海峡的人。英国人总是担心船只的出现。但它们也带来了新的开始。所以无论是尤利乌斯·凯撒的登陆，还是更贴切地说，盎格鲁-撒克逊人，你知道，亨吉斯特（Hengist）和霍萨（Horsa）在萨尼特（Thanet）的登陆。我的意思是，这是一个入侵的叙事，但它也是一个关于新开始和新机遇的叙事。所以，我的意思是，这是一个非常迷人的观点。我想我们应该在节目快结束时探讨一下，当我们审视“疾风号”所产生的共鸣时。
But you said that you experienced kind of feelings of irritation, but in your introduction, you also say that you experienced nostalgia when you see the pictures of the people descending the gangplanks from the Windrush at Tilbury. Again, I'm sure you're absolutely right that it's the iconic quality of the look, isn't it? It's an immediate kind of visual signifier. Because I live off Brixton Hill, and in the anniversary of the Windrush actually arising, there was a big street party at the top of our street. And there were lots of people who had come dressed in the dresses and the sharp suits of the people who came. And you just had to look at them to know what they were doing. You know, it was an immediate kind of visual spark. You knew exactly what the reference point was. And of course, that wouldn't work if we didn't
但你说你经历过一种恼火的感觉，但在你的引言中，你也说当你看到人们走下蒂尔伯里“疾风号”舷梯的照片时，你感到怀旧。同样，我相信你绝对是对的，这是一种标志性的外观特质，不是吗？这是一种直接的视觉符号。因为我住在布里克斯顿山（Brixton Hill），在“疾风号”抵达的周年纪念日，我们街头顶举办了一场大型街头派对。有很多人穿着当年人们穿的裙子和笔挺的西装。你只需要看他们一眼就知道他们在做什么。你知道，这是一种直接的视觉火花。你确切地知道参考点是什么。当然，如果我们没有
have the video footage. The way that people were dressed as they come off the boat in those pictures is significant, particularly if you come from this tradition, because what they are dressed in is what people used to call Sunday best. The women wear gloves, they wear hats. The men wear suits and ties with tie pins, and they also wear hats. The background that I come from, that's what you do if you're going to church. And if you're wearing these clothes, it's because it's an important moment and you're going to share something valuable, something significant in your life. It's not like we do these days, you know, get on a plane in your T-shirt and jeans. And if you're going somewhere important, you'll dress when you get there. I remember actually I was born in London, but as a child, shuffled a bit back and forth. I remember on one occasion
视频片段，那是不可能奏效的。人们在那些照片中下船时的着装方式意义重大，特别是如果你来自这个传统，因为他们穿的是人们过去常说的“周日最佳”（Sunday best）。女性戴着手套，戴着帽子。男性穿着西装，打着领带，戴着领带夹，也戴着帽子。在我成长的背景中，如果你要去教堂，你就会这样做。如果你穿着这些衣服，那是因为这是一个重要的时刻，你要去分享生活中宝贵、重要的事情。不像我们现在这样，你知道，穿着 T 恤和牛仔裤上飞机。如果你要去重要的地方，你会在到达后再换装。我记得实际上我出生在伦敦，但小时候来回搬迁。我记得有一次
when my parents sent me back to what was then British Guyana, I was on a plane and I was dressed in a tweed jacket and tie and shirt just for the journey. And so how old were you then? On that occasion, I would have been 12. So you're like Prince George. A bit, a bit, yes. Going to a football match. Yeah, exactly, exactly.
当我父母把我送回当时还是英属圭亚那（British Guyana）时，我坐飞机，我穿着粗花呢夹克、领带和衬衫，仅仅是为了旅途。那你当时多大？那次我应该是 12 岁。所以你就像乔治王子一样。有点，有点，是的。去看足球比赛。是的，完全正确，完全正确。
But the point is really that we recognise what that meant to those people, partly by the way they are dressed. You know, it is partly a thing that West Indians, as we would have called them at the time, and still Caribbean people, take a pride in the way we look. We are bothered about the way we dress in spite of the way I might look today. We think about these things. It's part of the culture. But I think it's more than that. It isn't just that because we've seen that style of dress in the movies and we see it in
但重点确实是我们通过他们的着装方式，认出了这对那些人意味着什么。你知道，这在一定程度上是西印度群岛人——正如我们当时所称呼的那样，现在仍然是加勒比人——引以为豪的事情。尽管我今天可能看起来这样，但我们确实很在意我们的穿着。我们考虑这些事情。这是文化的一部分。但我认为这不仅仅是那样。这不仅仅是因为我们在电影中看到了那种着装风格，我们在
you know the pictures of the dance halls and so on they dressed like that because this was an important journey an important moment and they were encountering the future in a way in a parallel way to the way that we might encounter the Almighty on a Sunday morning. And if you're going to encounter the Almighty, you show some respect. So Trevor, for those of our listeners who are not super familiar with this story, especially our international listeners, could you tell us a bit about the historical background to all this? So the boat, the SS Empire Windrush, left Kingston on the 8th of June 1948, it docked at Tilbury on the 22nd. As you said, there's almost 500 migrants from the Caribbean. So first of all, maybe tell us a bit
你知道，舞厅的照片等等中看到了，他们那样穿是因为这是一次重要的旅程，一个重要的时刻，他们正在以一种平行的方式遇见未来，就像我们可能在周日上午遇见全能者一样。如果你要遇见全能者，你会表现出一些尊重。所以特雷弗，对于我们那些不太熟悉这个故事的听众，特别是我们的国际听众，你能告诉我们一些关于这一切的历史背景吗？所以那艘船，“帝国疾风号”，于 1948 年 6 月 8 日离开金斯顿，于 22 日停靠在蒂尔伯里。正如你所说，有近 500 名来自加勒比海的移民。所以首先，也许告诉我们一些
about who these people are and why they're coming, because that in itself is a much debated story, isn't it, about whether it's push or pull and what is drawing people to the United Kingdom. Look, the first thing I think that everybody has to remember is that this was the British Empire. And what those words have come to mean, I think in recent times have been rather narrow. They've become essentially code for cruelty and repression and domination by the centre. I think what is important to understand is that for people at the time, there was that. And of course, there was the anti-colonial movement, people in islands or in countries like my own family, British Guiana, had got to a place where they wanted people who
关于这些人是谁以及他们为什么来，因为这本身就是一个备受争议的故事，不是吗，关于它是推力还是拉力，以及是什么吸引人们来到英国。看，我认为每个人首先要记住的是，这是大英帝国。我认为这些词在最近一段时间的含义已经变得相当狭隘。它们基本上变成了残酷、压迫和中心统治的代名词。我认为重要的是要理解，对于当时的人们来说，确实有那一面。当然，还有反殖民运动，在岛屿或像我家族所在的国家——英属圭亚那——的人们已经到了一个他们想要当地人——不仅仅是种族问题，而是生活在这片土地上的人——来掌控自己命运的地步，而不是等待 5000 英里外议会中那些从未去过、从未经历过我们生活的人的指示或立法。但我认为我的父母和祖父母会把自己视为当时他们可能称之为“全球兄弟会”的一部分。记住，反殖民运动从加勒比海延伸到非洲。在第三世界成为领导人的男女们在这里，在英国相遇，他们并没有把时间花在思考白人对他们做了什么上。他们会思考彼此。
were local, not purely a racial thing, people who lived on the soil to be in charge of their own destiny, not to have to wait for instructions or legislation from people 5,000 miles away in a parliament who had never been and experienced our lives. But I think that my parents and grandparents would have seen themselves as part of what in those days they might have called a global brotherhood. Remember that the anti-colonial movement stretched across the Caribbean to Africa. Men and women who became leaders in the third world met here in England, and they didn't just spend their time thinking about what white people do to them. They'd be thinking about each other.
所以当战争爆发时，我认为值得记住的是，许多人，比如我父亲，他当时在军队里，把自己视为这个对抗法西斯的全球帝国的一部分。所以达德利·汤普森（Dudley Thompson），后来成为牙买加外交部长，说他走进了一家牙医诊所。我不知道这是怎么发生的。但无论如何，他说牙医桌上有一本《我的奋斗》。他拿起它，读了读，开始看到关于像他这样的黑人的参考，称他们为“半类人猿”（semi-anthropoidal），这是他使用的词。他说，我对此感到被侮辱了。我要去欧洲，我要踢希特勒的屁股，然后我要回家，这正是他所做的。他作为飞行中尉执行了数十次任务，许多志愿加入英国皇家空军（RAF）的加勒比人也是如此。这是“疾风号”的重要背景。我们选择那艘船的另一个原因是，船上的许多人都是在英国服过役、回过家，老实说，觉得家里有点无聊的人，
So when war broke out, I think it's worth remembering that lots of people, like my own father who was in the army, saw themselves as part of this worldwide empire fighting against fascism. So Dudley Thompson, who later became the foreign minister of Jamaica, says he went into a dentist. I don't know how this happened. But anyway, he said that there's a copy of Mein Kampf on the dentist table. He picked it up, read it, started to see references to black people like himself as semi-anthropoidal is the word he uses. And he said, I'm insulted by this. I'm going to go to Europe and I'm going to kick Hitler's ass and I'm going to come home, which is exactly what he did. He flew dozens of missions as a flight lieutenant, as did many Caribbean men who volunteered for the RAF. And that's important background to Windrush. One of the other reasons we chose that boat is that many of the men on that boat were people who had served in the war in England, had gone home, to be honest, had found home a bit boring
并且想回到英国，因为他们经历过，你知道，那太可怕了。我的意思是，当我读回这些资料时，我仍然感到动容，他们谈论这样一个事实：他们和来自特立尼达和牙买加的同学一起来。他们坐上这些飞机，或者他们是工程师。汤普森确实谈到了看到他的一位同学飞进山里并丧生。我的意思是，这些人经历了战争，也死于战争。也许有一点肾上腺素瘾，我不知道，但他们想回来。这不仅仅是一个穷人想要来到富裕地方的故事。他们想要一种不同的生活。我认为我们对各种移民仍然存在的一个误解是认为
and wanted to come back to England because they'd had, you know, it had been terrible. I mean, I still find it moving when I read back, They talk about the fact that they had come with their classmate from Trinidad and Jamaica. They went up in these planes or they were engineers. And Thompson does talk about seeing one of his classmates flying into a hill and dying. I mean, these men lived and died the war. And maybe there was a little bit of the adrenaline junkie, I don't know, but they wanted to come back. It wasn't just a story of people who were poor wanting to come and be in a rich place. They wanted a different life. One of the things that I think we still get wrong about immigrants of all kinds is to think that
你提到了推力和拉力，认为他们基本上是在逃避某种可怕的事情。实际上，对于大多数来到这个国家和美国的移民来说，更真实的是他们是冒险者。他们是村子里那些不想忍受父母所做之事的人。他们想要更多。他们是有野心的人。你知道，他们是那些想要做点特别事情的人。这就是“疾风号”航行对我所代表的意义。所以特雷弗，你引用了一个名叫尤顿·克里斯蒂安（Euton Christian）的人的话，他乘坐“疾风号”来到这里，他有着令人惊叹的传记。就像你提到的几个人一样，他在 1944 年加入了皇家空军，然后他参加了曼彻斯特之战，多米尼克。那是
you mentioned push and pull, that what they're doing is basically escaping something terrible. Actually, what is more true about most immigrants who turn up in this country and the United States is that they are the adventurous ones. They are the ones in the village who don't want to put up with what their parents did. They want more. They're the ambitious ones. You know, they're the ones who want to do something special. And that's what the Windrush Voyages represented to me. So Trevor, you quote a man called Euton Christian, who comes over on the Windrush, and he has an astonishing biography. So like several of the men that you've mentioned, he joins the RAF in 1944, and then he takes part in the Battle of Manchester, Dominic. It was one of
美国白人军队当局试图强加种族隔离的冲突之一。在曼彻斯特发生了一场战斗，以确保酒吧对美国黑人军人开放。非裔美国军人参与其中，西印度群岛军人参与其中，英国曼彻斯特白人也参与其中。所以这已经让故事变得复杂了，不是吗？然后他乘坐“疾风号”返回，后来他成为了曼彻斯特的市议员，成为了该市第一位黑人地方法官，于 2010 年去世。所以这是一个非凡的故事。但你引用他的话说，作为一个在学校长大的年轻人，我们总是把英国视为“母国”。出于这个原因，她被
those clashes between white American army authorities trying to impose segregation. And there's this kind of battle in Manchester to ensure that the pubs are open to black American servicemen. African American servicemen are taking part, West Indian servicemen, and white British Mancunians are taking part. So that's kind of complicating the story already, isn't it? And then he returns in the Windrush and in due course, he goes on to become a town councillor in Manchester, becomes the city's first black magistrate, dies in 2010. So extraordinary story. But you quote him saying, as a young man growing up in school, we always regarded England as the mother country. And for that reason, she was
视为一位很少见到孩子的父母，但孩子们会想到国外的父母。所以你刚才描述自己穿上西装回圭亚那。但从某种意义上说，他们穿西装是因为他们要去看望母国，如果你要去看望父母，你会打扮一番吗？对他们中的一些人来说，有这方面的因素吗？我的意思是，我不想让它听起来很卑微。不是那样的。
regarded as a parent who never often sees the children, but the children think of the parents abroad. So you were describing yourself being put in a suit to go back to Guyana. But in a sense, are they wearing the suits because they're coming to see the mother country and you dress up if you're going to see your parents? Is there some aspect of that for some of them? I mean, I don't want to make it sound servile. It's not quite like that.
在加勒比海，我们有一种尊重的传统，而不是顺从。你为某人打扮并不一定意味着你认为他们比你优越，尽管对某些人来说可能有一点这种成分。那么，关于“疾风号”上的人，大多数是独自一人的年轻男性，你认为特雷弗，总的来说，人们是在想“我要去开启新生活并永久定居”，还是很多人在想“我不知道，谁知道呢，走着瞧吧”，或者有些人是在想
We have in the Caribbean a tradition of respect rather than deference. The fact that you dress up for somebody doesn't necessarily mean that you think they're better than you, though there might be some of that for some people. So just on the the people on the windrush the majority are young men on their own and do you think trevor by and large people are thinking i'm going to make a new life and settle permanently or a lot of people thinking i don't know who knows let's just see how it goes or some people thinking
听着，这只会持续两三年，赚点钱，看看世界，然后我就回家。绝对是后者。对他们大多数人来说，绝对是后者。想法是，你会来，你会花一些时间，特别是对于年轻男性，你会玩得开心，有一些冒险，你会存一些钱，你会寄一些钱回家。当你存够了钱，你就会回家，你会盖一栋新房子，你会在你的村子里成为国王。对。
listen it's just going to be for two or three years, make a bit of money, see the world, then I'll come back home. Absolutely the latter. For most of them, absolutely the latter. The idea was that what you do, you would come, you would spend some time, particularly for the young men, you'd have some fun, some adventure, you'd save up some money, you'd send some money home. And when you got enough, you'd go home, you would build a new house, and you'd be a king in your village. Right.
这基本上就是那个想法。顺便说一句，这至少对几乎一代人来说都是真实的。你知道，我自己的父母，他们 1950 年来的，他们心里一直想着要回家。我有九个兄弟姐妹。我是最小的一个，也是唯一一个在这里出生的。所以一直有一种活跃的交流。我和我的兄弟姐妹会回去待一段时间。事实上，我大部分童年是在英属圭亚那，后来成为圭亚那度过的。我童年中间只在这里待了四五年。所以意图确实一直是我们会回家。在我们家庭的情况下发生的事情是，我的父母在 60 年代末，1967 年，决定他们受够了。他们要回家。他们经由美国，我们一直有家族分支在那里。大多数西印度群岛人
That's basically the idea. And that, by the way, was true for at least almost a generation. You know, my own parents, they came in 1950, they always had in their minds, they'd return home. I had nine siblings. I was the last and I was the only one born here. So there was always a sort of active exchange. Me and my siblings would go and spend time back home. In fact, I spent most of my childhood in British Guyana and then what became Guyana. I was only here for four or five years in the middle of my childhood. So the intention was always really that we would go home. What happened in our family's case is that my parents in the late 60s, 1967, decided they had enough. They were going back home. They went via the United States where we'd always have a branch of the family. Most West Indians
一直都有家族分支在美国，因为人们会季节性地去采棉花等等，他们被困住了。实际上现在发生的是，我的一半家庭现在是一个美国家庭。所以回到你的观点，我不认为意图曾经是来并留下来。同样，你必须记住，你谈论的是那些在一个地方扎根对他们来说是一件陌生事情的人。你知道，我自己的家族在圭亚那只待了一个世纪。他们之前在巴巴多斯。我们知道原因，因为在那个时候，任何人都可以把我们带走，把我们搬到他们想要的任何地方。所以那种来并留下的想法在他们的世界里真的不会存在。事实证明，对他们中的许多人来说，
have always had a branch of the family in the United States because people would go cotton picking seasonally and so on, and they got stuck. And actually what's now happened is half my family is now an American family. So the point to your point, I don't think the intention was ever to come and stay. And again, you have to remember, you're talking about people for whom being in one place and putting down roots is an unfamiliar thing. You know, my own family had only been in Guyana for a century. They had previously been in Barbados. And we know why, because at that time, anybody could pick us up and move us wherever they wanted. So the idea of sort of coming and staying wouldn't really have been part of their universe. As things turned out for many of them,
实际上，他们确实留下来了。特雷弗，我能问你 1948 年“疾风号”抵达时，英国当局的态度吗？因为我有一种相当模糊的两个矛盾的假设。一个是英国政府发出了邀请，因为劳动力有缺口需要填补。“你呼唤，我们来了”是那句名言。另一个是他们被——我想你说过——被种族主义焦虑所困扰，并尽其所能阻止移民。你指出这些是矛盾的，基本上它们都不完全是真的。正如我在开头读到的那段话中所看到的，基本上这种焦虑是一种公务员式的焦虑，即人们
actually, that is what they did. And Trevor, can I ask you in 1948, when Windrush arrived, the attitudes of the British authorities, because I kind of rather inchoately had two contradictory assumptions about it. One was that the British government had issued invitations that there were gaps in the labour force to be filled. You called and we came is the famous line. And the other one is that they're kind of crippled with, I think you say, stricken with racist anxiety and doing everything in their power to stop the migrants. And you point out that these are kind of contradictory and that basically neither of them really are true. And as we saw in that passage that I read at the start, basically the anxiety is a kind of civil service anxiety that people
在做他们不应该做的事情。这是战后时期那种确保每个人都知道自己在做什么的愿望的反映。对于听众来说，你们必须记住的一件事是，在那个时候，乔治敦和伦敦之间没有障碍。没有法律或公民身份的障碍。我的父母拥有每个人都有的同样的蓝色护照。没有移民限制。他们不需要签证之类的东西。他们基本上只是上了船，就能来到这里，因为我们都是大英帝国的一部分。我们都是当时国王的臣民。我认为当局的态度源于两件事。首先，你必须记住
are doing what they shouldn't be doing. And this is a reflection of the kind of desire of the war period to make sure that everyone knows what they're doing. For listeners, one of the things you've got to remember is that at that point, there was no barrier between Georgetown and London. There was no legal or citizenship barrier. My parents had the same blue passport that everybody here had. There was no immigration bar. They didn't have to have visas or anything like that. They basically just got on the boat and could come here because we were all part of this British Empire. We were all subjects of the then king. I think that the attitude of the authorities derives from two things. First of all, you've got to remember the
大英帝国在其他方面是一个巨大的劳动力市场机器。伦敦的公务员习惯于把人从世界的一个地方转移到世界的另一个地方来解决问题，经济问题。例如，圭亚那和特立尼达是印度洋以外仅有的两个人口中印度裔占多数的国家。原因是在奴隶制之后，我的意思是，你知道，我们的人民，我的祖先，决定受够了进入甘蔗田并死去，因为例如在牙买加种植园，奴隶进入田地后的预期寿命大约只有八年。所以英国殖民当局从印度，特别是比哈尔邦，运送了大量人口到加勒比海在甘蔗田工作。我认为殖民当局仍然是那种心态。如果人们从帝国的一个地方转移，那一定是由伦敦推动的。所以那种想法是
British Empire was, amongst other things, a great labour market machine. And the civil service in London were used to moving people from one part of the world to another part of the world to fix problems, economic problems. So, for example, Guyana and Trinidad are the only countries outside of the Indian Ocean where the majority of the population is of Indian origin. And the reason for that is because after slavery, I mean, you know, our people, my ancestors, decided had enough of going into the cane fields and dying because the life expectancy of a slave in a Jamaican plantation, for example, was about eight years after you'd entered the fields. So the British colonial authorities shipped a lot of people from India, Bihar particularly, to the Caribbean to work in the cane fields. And I think the colonial authorities were still of that mentality. If people were moving from one part of the empire, it had to be motivated by London. So the idea that
有些人可以自作主张地上一艘船，从帝国的一个地方搬到另一个地方，这真的很令人震惊。另一个方面是，有一种关于这些奇怪的深色皮肤的人出现的道德恐慌。我想我们在书中没有真正谈论这个。我认为这是一个重要的问题，我不确定我是否有答案。但我的假设是，你提到的那一点，比如，白人军官和黑人美国大兵之间的骚乱，他们想，我们不想在这里发生任何那种事，这可能会成为一个问题。而且你还必须记住，这也是在帝国各地，在非洲等地，因为那里的反殖民运动而爆发各种骚乱的背景下。我认为在这种背景下，你可以看出为什么
some people could take it upon themselves just to get on a boat and move from one part of the empire to another was really shocking. The other aspect of it was that there was a kind of moral panic about these strange, dark people turning up. I think we don't really talk about this in the book. I think it's an important question to which I'm not sure I have any answer. But my hypothesis would be that the point that you mentioned, if you like, example, disturbances between white officers and black GIs thought, we don't want any of that here, and this might become a problem. And you also have to remember, this was also against a background where there were all sorts of disturbances breaking out across the empire in Africa and so on, because of the anti-colonial movements there. I think against that background, you could see why
人们会说，嗯。我的意思是，这太歇斯底里了。他们派了一艘军舰去跟踪“疾风号”。是的，那太惊人了。我的意思是，这很奇怪，不是吗？一艘驱逐舰去跟踪一艘船，船上有一些家伙，他们只是来工作、找工作和去夜总会的。对。我想我们应该在那一点上休息一下。特雷弗，也许当我们回来时，我们可以看看“疾风号”抵达后的岁月，
people would be going, hmm. I mean, it was hysterical. They sent a warship to shadow the Windrush. Yeah, that's amazing. I mean, it's bizarre, isn't it? A destroyer to shadow a boat which has some blokes in it who are just coming to go to work and find work and go to nightclubs. Right. I think we should take a break at that point. And Trevor, maybe when we come back, we could look at the years that follow the arrival of the Windrush
看看它更广泛的背景。所以我们休息后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的
and look at the kind of the broader context of it. So we'll be back after a break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our
问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。板球，可爱的板球，在罗德板球场（Lords），我看到亚德利（Yardley）尽了最大努力，但戈达德（Goddard）赢得了测试赛，带着我的那些小伙子们，拉马丁（Ramadin）和瓦伦丁（Valentine），那是罗德·贝吉纳（Lord Beginner）在庆祝西印度群岛 1950 年在罗德板球场战胜英格兰。多米尼克，你还记得我们在世界杯那一集中谈到英格兰在 1950 年世界杯上输给美国吗？多米尼克，你还记得我们在世界杯那一集中谈到英格兰在世界杯上输给美国吗？在 1950 年。
q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com cricket lovely cricket at lords where i saw it yardley did his best but goddard won the test with those little pals of mine ramadin and valentine that was lord beginner celebrating the victory of west indies at lords over england in 1950 dominic do you remember in the world cup episode we did and we talked about england losing to the united states in the world cup in 1950. Dominic, do you remember in the World Cup episode we did and we talked about England losing to the United States in the World Cup? In 1950.
以及为什么英格兰没有人真正关注它，因为那种震惊。是的，我记得。西印度群岛在罗德板球场取得的这场胜利。所以对于国际主义者，顺便说一句，汤姆刚才在谈论板球。抱歉。汤姆，你没有费心提到你在谈论什么运动。大多数人不会知道那是什么。我以为这很明显。
And how nobody in England really paid any attention to it because of the shock. Yes, I do remember that. Of this defeat at Lord's that the West Indies had won. So for the internationalists, by the way, Tom was talking about cricket. Sorry. Tom, you didn't bother to mention what sport you were talking about. Most people won't know what it will be. I thought it was obvious.
所以英格兰输给了瓦伦丁和桑尼·拉马丁（Sonny Ramadin）出色的旋转投球，特雷弗，他是第一批为西印度群岛效力的印度裔球员之一，我想，你在休息前谈到过。这是一个象征性的时刻，不是吗？但我提到它是合理的。哦，是的。我的意思是，这是一个重大的心理事件。记住，板球是英格兰的运动。从历史上看，高级竞争，如果我可以这样说的话，一直被认为是
So England lost to brilliant spin bowling of Valentine and Sonny Ramadin, who Trevor was one of, I think, the first Indian players to play for the West Indies. You were talking about before the break. And it's a kind of symbolic moment, isn't it? But justifiable for me to mention it. Oh, yes. I mean, it was a major psychological thing. Bear in mind, cricket was England's game. And historically, the senior rivalry, if I can put it that way, would have always thought to
在英格兰和澳大利亚之间。这些是严肃的球队。西印度群岛打板球，但这是一种绅士运动。我认为在那一点之前，象征性地，西印度群岛队的队长正在成为所有西印度群岛人的财产，而不仅仅是殖民主人，正如我们当时使用的短语。所以当那支球队来到英格兰并获胜时，拉马丁和瓦伦丁，他们是旋转大师，我想我们今天会这样说，他们之间拿下了大量的出局数，我想是 50 多个，对于那些不关注板球的人来说，这很多。我的意思是，那是历史性的。这是一种心理冲击，因为突然间有了一些
have been between England and Australia. These were the serious teams. The West Indies played cricket, but it was a sort of gentleman's game. And I think until that point, symbolically, the captain of the West Indies team had team was becoming the property of all West Indians, not just the colonial masters, as we would have used the phrase at that time. So when that team came to England and won, and Ramadan and Valentine, who were spinmeisters, I think we'd say today, took vast numbers of wickets between them, 50-something, I think, which for those who don't follow cricket is a lot. I mean, that is historic. It was a psychological shock because suddenly there was something
一直处于二流的人可以打败英国人的东西。英国人并不介意被澳大利亚人打败，因为，你知道，我们是同类人。但被这些人打败说明了一些重要的事情。当然，同样，它是在有独立煽动的政治背景下。我们在印度独立三四年后，这对英国人来说也是一个重大的心理事件。所以几年后，当哈罗德·麦克米伦（Harold Macmillan）谈到“变革之风”时，他当时谈论的是南非，它们已经在吹过这个国家了。它实现了今天政界人士所说的“穿透力”。而且它是在这样一个背景下发生的，
that people who had always been second division could beat the English at. The English didn't mind being beaten by the Australians because that's, you know, we're the same sort of people. But being beaten by these people said something important. And of course, again, it was against a political background where there was agitation for independence. We were three, four years after the independence of India, which had also been a major psychological event for the British. So when a few years later, Harold Macmillan talked about winds of change, he was talking about South Africa at that time, they were already blowing through this country. It achieved what today people in politics would call cut through. And it comes against the background of,
你在上半场提到，1948 年“疾风号”停靠时，船上绝大多数人可能都预计几年后会回家。但显然，接下来的——是多少年？12 年——故事是越来越多的人抵达并留下来，以至于到 1960 年代末，所以跳跃一下，大约有 25 万人，我想，从加勒比海抵达英国。如果你包括印度和巴基斯坦，这显然是另一个故事，但如果你包括这些，英国的黑人和南亚人口现在有 65 万之多。那么从 1948 年开始，发生了什么变化，意味着这现在已经变成了一个永久定居的故事？好吧，一件事是你说的数量。同样，在今天的背景下，很难想象，
you mentioned in the first half that probably the large majority of the people on the Windrush when it docks in 1948 are anticipating going back home after a few years. But obviously the story in the next, what is it, 12 years effectively, is one of more and more people arriving and staying, such that by the end of the 1960s, so jumping ahead, there are about a quarter of a million people, I think, who have arrived from the Caribbean in Britain. And if you include India and Pakistan, which is obviously a different story, but if you include that, you have a black and South Asian population in Britain, which is now 650,000 strong. So what has changed from 1948 onwards to mean that this has now become a story of permanent settlement? Well, one thing is that you said volume. Again, in today's context, it's hard to imagine,
但净移民，我想 50 年代上半叶来自加勒比海的绝对移民人数每年不会超过 4000 或 5000 人。现在我们谈论的是 50 万的净移民。想到它引起的恐慌令人惊讶。但当然，部分原因是由于冲突，由于不熟悉等等。不过你问的是，实际上发生了什么变化，以及何时发生的。我会说，巨大的变化发生在 1960 年代上半叶。在那段时期发生的事情是孩子。第一批主要是男性。但当然，你随后有成群的女性到来。例如，我自己的家庭来的原因是因为，
but net migration, I think absolute migration from the Caribbean for the first part of the 50s wouldn't have broken 4,000 or 5,000 individuals a year. Now we're talking about net migration of half a million. It's surprising to think of the panic that that engendered. But of course, part of that was because of conflicts, because of unfamiliarity, and so on. You've asked, though, what actually changed and when. I would say that the big change took place in the first half of the 1960s. And the thing that happened in that period was children. The first cohorts were mostly male. But of course, what you then had were groups of women coming. For example, the reason that my own family came was because,
除其他原因外，我姐姐想成为一名护士。在那个时候，加勒比海的机会有限。所以她来了，她成为了一名护士。她在伦敦受训，实际上是在格拉斯哥，甚至在巴黎的索邦大学待过一段时间。所以更多的女性来了。现在，有一个故事是这样说的，“你呼唤，我们来了”。那不是真的，一开始根本没有那种事，后来在 50 年代中期、50 年代末才变得真实。是的，随后而来的是浪漫和孩子，我认为大多数这些家庭必须做出决定的事情是，你现在该怎么办？在某些情况下，像我自己的家庭，因为我出生时我们已经是一个大家庭了，我姐姐已经成年了，你可以做各种各样的事情，你可以把小的
amongst other things, my sister wanted to be a nurse. And at that time, the opportunities were limited in the Caribbean. So she came and she became a nurse. She trained in London, in Glasgow, in fact, even had a period in Sorbonne in Paris. And so more women came. Now, there is a story that is told that, you know, you called, we came. That was not true at the beginning there was none of that it then became true later in the mid 50s late 50s yeah what then followed was romance and children and what i think most of those families would have had to make a decision about is what do you then do now in some cases like my own family because we were already such a big family by the time I was born my older sister was an adult you could do a variety of things you could send the younger
送回家等等，但我认为对于年轻人来说，他们只是必须做出决定，我们是要尝试在这里抚养我们的孩子，还是我们要回家？你可以看到，对于那些迈出这一大步进入未知世界的人来说，在冒险完成之前回家，即在你作为一个有钱、有能力盖房子和买农场的人回家之前，那将是羞辱性的。你不会那样做。所以人们留下来了，他们说，好吧，我们再待几年，我们会到达我们想要的地方，一点一点地，随后发生的事情是他们被困住了，你知道，你有一个五岁的孩子，或者你有一个 10 岁的孩子，你然后把他们连根拔起吗？不，这就是我认为在 1960 年代发生的事情，我们有了孩子，他们基本上变成了英国人。
ones home and so on but I think for younger people they just had to make a decision are we going to try and bring up our children here or are we going to go back home and you can see that for people who had made this big leap into the unknown going going back before the adventure was complete, i.e. before you had raised and saved enough money to go home as a serious person with enough money to build your house and buy a farm, for example, that would have been humiliating. You're not going to do that. So people stayed and they said, said okay we'll do a few more years we'll get to the place where we wanted to and bit by bit what then happens is they got stuck and you know you have a child who's five or you have a child who's 10 do you then uproot them no and that's what happened i think in the 1960s we had children and they became largely english
比如家乡等等，但我认为对于年轻人来说，他们不得不做出决定：我们是要在这里抚养孩子，还是回老家？你可以看出，对于那些迈出这一大步进入未知世界的人来说，在冒险结束之前——也就是说，在你攒够钱、能以一个体面人的身份带着足够的钱回家盖房买地之前——就打道回府，那将是极其丢脸的。你不会那样做。所以人们留了下来，他们说，好吧，我们再待几年，等达到我们想要的目标。就这样一点一点地，他们被困住了。你知道，当你的孩子五岁或十岁时，你还会把他们连根拔起吗？不会。我认为这就是20世纪60年代发生的事情，我们有了孩子，而他们最终在很大程度上变成了英国人。
children well that's a key question isn't it so i mean clearly those children were english children in the 1960s, we had children, and they became largely English children. Well, that's a key question, isn't it? So, I mean, clearly, those children were English children. But that first generation of children born in Britain, obviously, they are growing up in a society that some people today would look often extremely racist. You know, they are abused in the street. Sometimes they're abused in the street sometimes. They're abused in the school playground. They're harassed by the police in the 1970s infamously, which lies behind a lot of the resentments that you then get exploding into rage on the streets and so on and so forth. So against that background, and I know this is inviting you to give a series of massive
孩子们，这是一个关键问题，不是吗？我的意思是，很明显，那些孩子是20世纪60年代的英国孩子，我们有了孩子，他们很大程度上成为了英国孩子。好吧，这是一个关键问题，不是吗？所以，我的意思是，很明显，那些孩子是英国孩子。但第一代在英国出生的孩子，显然，他们是在一个今天有些人看来极其种族主义的社会中长大的。你知道，他们在街上受到虐待。有时他们在街上受到虐待，有时在学校操场上受到虐待。20世纪70年代，他们臭名昭著地受到警察的骚扰，这导致了后来在街头爆发的愤怒等等。所以，在这样的背景下，我知道这是在邀请你给出一些宏大的概括，但在这个背景下，那些第一代在英国出生的人，我的意思是，我猜他们并不以一种简单的方式看待自己是英国人，因为他们大概被夹在两个世界之间。
generalizations, but against that background, do those people who are the first generation to be born in Britain, I mean, I'm guessing they don't see themselves in an uncomplicated way English because they're caught between two worlds, presumably. Well, you know, I'm the earliest part of that generation. And I think you've got to think about how people see themselves and what they actually think about. First of all, I don't think anybody ever really sort of sits down and writes themselves an essay. Am I English or am I not English? People only really think about that when they're asked the question, when somebody else says, what are you?
好吧，你知道，我是那一代人中最早的一部分。我认为你必须思考人们是如何看待自己的，以及他们实际上在想什么。首先，我不认为有人真的会坐下来给自己写一篇论文。我是英国人还是不是英国人？人们只有在被问到这个问题时，当别人问你是什么人时，才会真正去思考这个问题。
And the answer might vary according to circumstances even now for example if i go to countries where people assume because i'm black and i speak english that i'm probably american i'll say i'm english or british whereas if i talk to a black person here and they say where are you from i know what they mean is, where's your family from? So I think we first got to understand in what circumstances people think they need to answer that question about their identity. For that first generation, I think the questions that you asked mattered when you felt that you were being treated differently to those around you. And I think rather than thinking I've got to make a choice between, you know, being Caribbean, being English, I don't think that's the
即使是现在，答案也可能因情况而异。例如，如果我去那些因为我是黑人且说英语而认为我可能是美国人的国家，我会说我是英国人。而如果我在这里和一个黑人交谈，他们问我你是哪里人，我知道他们的意思是，你的家人来自哪里？所以我认为我们首先要了解人们在什么情况下认为他们需要回答关于他们身份的问题。对于第一代人来说，我认为你问的问题很重要，当你觉得你受到与周围人不同的对待时。我认为与其认为我必须在加勒比人或英国人之间做出选择，我不认为这是
way certainly anybody in my generation would have thought about it. I think it would have started from the premise, why don't you accept that I'm a Londoner? What's wrong with you? I don't think there's a sort of philosophical choice here. It would present itself more as, why is this person not recognising who and what I am? So I think that the answer is that most of that generation would think of themselves as English. You know, there's a lot of writing and there's a lot of music and so on, which presents it differently. But in truth, most of the people who are born here, unlike me, weren't thinking of themselves as people with two different homes.
我那一代人肯定会考虑的方式。我认为这会从一个前提开始：为什么你不接受我是伦敦人？你有什么毛病？我不认为这里存在某种哲学上的选择。它更多地表现为：为什么这个人不承认我是谁以及我是什么？所以我认为答案是，那一代人的大多数人会认为自己是英国人。你知道，有很多文章、音乐等等，呈现出不同的观点。但事实上，大多数在这里出生的人，不像我，并没有把自己看作是有两个不同家园的人。
They would be thinking, this is my home, this is who I am. And the rage that you mentioned would come from being treated as though that was not the case by other people. So i don't think it was ever really yeah a question yeah so trevor your book windrush and the documentary you made came out in 1998 yeah so that was to mark the 50th anniversary of the arrival of the windrush and 1998 is you know the black government is in power and very, they will open the gates to a very large wave of immigration from Europe. So it's often forgotten that there were 60 Polish women, I think, on the Windrush as well when it came. Some of them come from Siberia, kind of incredible
他们会认为，这是我的家，这就是我。而你提到的愤怒来自于被其他人当作并非如此对待。所以我认为这从来都不是一个问题。是的，特雷弗，你的书《疾风号》（Windrush）和你们制作的纪录片是在1998年出版的，对吧？那是为了纪念“疾风号”抵达50周年。1998年，你知道，工党政府上台了，他们将打开大门，迎接来自欧洲的大规模移民潮。所以人们经常忘记，当“疾风号”到来时，上面还有60名波兰妇女。她们中的一些人来自西伯利亚，经历了一段不可思议的
journey via India and Palestine. And do you think that the fact that immigration to Britain over the past decades has not kind of been from the traditional Commonwealth countries? Has that complicated the narrative, do you think, since you wrote the first version of the book in 1998? By complicating it, I mean the sense of the wind rush as the foundational myth at the start of what Britain has become over the past decades. Yes, complicated in two different ways, one of which is incorrect, and one of which I think is an important way. The incorrect way is for people who think of all immigration as a sort of uniform wave. The truth is that the Caribbean wave of immigration was very different from that that
旅程，途经印度和巴勒斯坦。你认为过去几十年来英国的移民并非来自传统的英联邦国家，这一事实是否使叙事变得复杂了？自从你在1998年写了第一版书以来，你认为这是否使叙事变得复杂了？通过使其复杂化，我的意思是将“疾风号”视为过去几十年英国所演变而成的基础神话。是的，以两种不同的方式变得复杂，其中一种是不正确的，而我认为另一种是重要的方式。不正确的方式是针对那些将所有移民视为一种统一浪潮的人。事实是，加勒比移民潮与后来
came a little bit later from the Punjab and from Pakistan. And again, the wave that came 2004, 2005 from Eastern Europe. And these are all quite different phenomena. And I think for people who don't recognize that, it's all a bit confusing. But I think smart people do recognize that. The wave that makes the Windrush story different, actually, is something slightly different. When we wrote Windrush, we were writing an origin story about people like myself and Mike, whose parents would have come in that post-war period, whose parents would largely have been people from the Caribbean who were Black, spoke English, were Christians. And that was what we, I suppose, wrote as an origin story of what we would now call Black Britain.
来自旁遮普和巴基斯坦的移民潮非常不同。同样，2004年、2005年来自东欧的浪潮也是如此。这些都是完全不同的现象。我认为对于那些不承认这一点的人来说，这有点令人困惑。但我认为聪明的人确实认识到了这一点。实际上，使“疾风号”故事与众不同的浪潮是稍微不同的东西。当我们写《疾风号》时，我们是在写一个关于像我和迈克这样的人的起源故事，他们的父母是在战后时期来到这里的，他们的父母大多是来自加勒比海的黑人，说英语，是基督徒。我想，这就是我们所写的我们现在称之为“黑人英国”的起源故事。
The thing is that since 1998, two dramatic things have happened. First of all, has been the emergence of a different black wave, as it were, from Africa. I'd sometimes refer to the way we came as the cruise route, cruising from West Africa to the Caribbean and then the Caribbean here. But those who came directly from Africa now outnumber us quite significantly. There are probably about 600,000 or 700,000 people like me in this country, Caribbean heritage, two black parents and so on. There are a million and a half people who've come direct from Africa. And they are a very different proposition. Their backgrounds are different, their expectations are different,
问题是，自1998年以来，发生了两件戏剧性的事情。首先，出现了另一种黑人浪潮，即来自非洲的浪潮。我有时把我们来的路线称为巡游路线，从西非巡游到加勒比海，然后再到这里。但现在直接从非洲来的人数已经大大超过了我们。在这个国家，像我这样有加勒比血统、父母都是黑人的人大约有60万到70万。而直接从非洲来的人有一百五十万。他们的情况非常不同。他们的背景不同，期望不同，
and their trajectories in the society are very different. So, for example, a lot of those who came from West Africa, I think, would be people who had a higher education background, middle-class professionals, and their expectations of their own fortunes would be much higher than ours. The other thing, which I personally think is even more significant and more interesting, both domestically and globally, is the emergence of a very sizable mixed race population. They're probably now getting on for a million people who, like my own children and
他们在社会中的轨迹也非常不同。例如，我认为许多来自西非的人是受过高等教育背景、中产阶级专业人士，他们对自己命运的期望会比我们高得多。另一件事，我个人认为在国内外都更重要、更有趣，那就是一个非常庞大的混血人口的出现。他们现在可能已经接近一百万人，像我自己的孩子和
grandchildren, have at least one grandparent who is white and at least one grandparent who is black. So Trevor, just to quote you in your book, you say that this is the most significant dual heritage population born since the war anywhere in the developed world, which I found such a striking phrase. When I first thought about this, I thought, oh, I've got to be wrong. There's got to be some other group. For the last four or five years, I've actually tried to study this. If you look in Europe, there's a significant minority population. But by and large, it hasn't, as far as I know, until very recently, the numbers don't tell me that that group has intermarried. It is still very separate. It's still very North
孙辈一样，至少有一个祖父母是白人，至少有一个祖父母是黑人。那么特雷弗，引用你书中的话，你说这是战后发达国家中出生的人口中最重要的双重血统人口，我觉得这是一个非常引人注目的短语。当我第一次想到这一点时，我想，哦，我一定是错了。一定有其他群体。在过去的四五年里，我实际上试图研究这个问题。如果你看看欧洲，有一个重要的少数族裔人口。但总的来说，据我所知，直到最近，数字并没有告诉我那个群体已经通婚。它仍然非常独立。它仍然非常北
African. People speak Arabic at home and so on. Where there are big mixed race populations in the world, black, white, they are South Africa, Brazil, and the United States. And in each of those cases, those populations came about prior to the war, and frankly, during a period where the mixing wasn't always entirely voluntary. This is the only country where you've got a sizable mixed race population that identifies as mixed race, compared with the United States, by the way, where most black people are actually in some senses mixed race, but the one drop rule still applies socially, if not legally. If you've got an African ancestor in the United States, you're black. It doesn't matter how many generations back. Whereas here, we have a dual
非。人们在家里说阿拉伯语等等。世界上有大量混血人口的地方是南非、巴西和美国。在每种情况下，这些人口都是在战前出现的，坦率地说，是在混合并不总是完全自愿的时期。这是唯一一个拥有大量自认为是混血儿的混血人口的国家，顺便说一句，与美国相比，大多数黑人在某种意义上实际上是混血儿，但“一滴血规则”在社会上（如果不是在法律上）仍然适用。如果你在美国有非洲祖先，你就是黑人。无论追溯到多少代都不重要。而在这里，我们有一个双重
heritage population that identifies as such, and which has arisen in the last couple of generations, and it has arisen voluntarily through romance rather than coercion. And that, I think, is such an unusual phenomenon that we ought not to take it for granted and treat it casually. And it kind of passes under the radar, doesn't it? In a lot of discussion. It's a sort of rather British thing, isn't it? We're rather casual about these things. Oh, it just, it happens.
血统人口，他们自认为是这样，并且是在过去几代人中产生的，它是通过浪漫而非强制自愿产生的。我认为这是一个非常不寻常的现象，我们不应该认为这是理所当然的，也不应该随意对待。它有点被忽视了，不是吗？在很多讨论中。这是一种相当英国式的做法，不是吗？我们对这些事情相当随意。哦，它只是，它发生了。
And I've got a theory that all of this comes from the Elizabethan doctrine of toleration, which essentially says, well, leave people to get on with what they do, as long as they don't interfere with the central authority and throw their difference in our faces. And stuff happens. We all adjust a little bit when things change. And things just happen naturally by some kind of osmosis. And a century later, we look back and go, oh, oh, that's interesting. That happened. Let's get on with it. That's our way. And I think we treat this phenomenon that way. I think that's a mistake.
我有一个理论，这一切都源于伊丽莎白时代的宽容原则，该原则本质上说，好吧，让人们去做他们做的事，只要他们不干扰中央权威，不把他们的差异扔到我们脸上。事情就会发生。当事情发生变化时，我们都会稍微调整一下。事情只是通过某种渗透自然地发生了。一个世纪后，我们回头看，哦，哦，这很有趣。这发生了。让我们继续吧。这就是我们的方式。我认为我们以这种方式对待这种现象。我认为这是一个错误。
I think it is very unusual in this world to be a person who can claim more than one cultural and ethnic tradition completely as your own. And I don't know how that feels. Most of us don't know how that feels. And most people in the world do not know how that feels. And I think that's a fantastic thing. I think it's a huge advantage. It's like being bilingual only on steroids. And I think these are very, very special people. But how we deal with it and how they deal with it, we don't know yet. And it's still to be seen. I would love to see more writing, more history about this phenomenon than there currently is, because it's special, and we need to understand
我认为在这个世界上，能够完全声称拥有不止一种文化和民族传统的人是非常不寻常的。我不知道那是什么感觉。我们大多数人不知道那是什么感觉。世界上大多数人不知道那是什么感觉。我认为这是一件美妙的事情。我认为这是一个巨大的优势。这就像双语，只是加强版。我认为这些人非常、非常特别。但我们如何处理它，他们如何处理它，我们还不知道。这还有待观察。我很乐意看到更多关于这种现象的写作和历史，而不是目前的情况，因为它是特殊的，我们需要理解
it if we are going to get the best of it, if I can put it that way. Trevor, we're running out of time. And since you mentioned wanting more history, I want to take you back to the place of the Windrush in history. So you talked about when you wrote the book, the idea of it being an origin story, a kind of foundational moment. And you said there's an origin story for Black Britain. I think it's so interesting because, of course, right now, and this has been the case for, let's say, the last 10, 12 years or so, there have been a lot of publications.
它，如果我们想从中获得最好的结果，如果我可以这样说的话。特雷弗，我们的时间不多了。既然你提到想要更多的历史，我想带你回到“疾风号”在历史中的位置。所以你谈到了当你写这本书时，它作为一个起源故事、一个基础时刻的想法。你说这是“黑人英国”的起源故事。我认为这非常有趣，因为当然，现在，这种情况已经持续了，比如说，过去10、12年左右，有很多出版物。
There's been a lot of kind of cultural effort put into weaving a narrative which basically says the origin story of Black Britain is actually the origin story of Britain per se. There were Black legionaries on Hadrian's Wall. Henry VIII had a Black trumpeter. There were slaves in Georgian England, and so on and so forth. So if the Windrush is a transformative moment, if it's a shorthand for a transformative moment, which is the advent of so many people from the Caribbean in the late 1940s, 1950s, 1960s. And that this is an unusual moment. And of course, one of the things your book brings out is the range of reactions in Britain from people who say, oh, gosh, I've never seen a black person before and all this sort of thing.
有很多文化努力投入到编织一个叙事中，基本上说“黑人英国”的起源故事实际上就是英国本身的起源故事。哈德良长城上有黑人军团。亨利八世有一名黑人小号手。乔治亚时代的英国有奴隶，等等。所以如果“疾风号”是一个变革性的时刻，如果它是变革性时刻的简写，即20世纪40年代末、50年代、60年代大量来自加勒比海的人的到来。这是一个不寻常的时刻。当然，你的书揭示的一件事是英国人的反应范围，从那些说，哦，天哪，我以前从未见过黑人等等的人。
Those two things kind of jar with each other a little bit, don't they? Because either the Windrush is the transformative foundational moment or it isn't. And if there have always been lots of black people in Britain, then its significance is kind of diminished. How do you make sense of all that? I would say it's a transformative moment rather than the transformative moment. Let me go back to the reason that I originally tried to get the Windrush story off the ground as a piece of television. I was in my 40s and you know I'd written a lot. I'd been a journalist for a long time and I'd written a lot about black communities but I'd always been asked to write about black communities purely in relation to
这两件事有点相互冲突，不是吗？因为要么“疾风号”是变革性的基础时刻，要么它不是。如果英国一直有很多黑人，那么它的意义就会减弱。你如何理解这一切？我会说这是一个变革性的时刻，而不是那个变革性的时刻。让我回到我最初试图将“疾风号”故事作为电视节目推出的原因。我40多岁了，你知道我写了很多。我做了很长时间的记者，写了很多关于黑人社区的文章，但我总是被要求纯粹从
what the white people would think or do about us. There was very, very little said by anybody about who we actually were. And maybe this is a kind of arrogance, or more likely because I'd grown up in the Caribbean and I come from a big family that has a very strong sense of itself. I just got fed up of being treated as though what happens is I wake up every morning and I think, what are my white neighbors going to think about me? Actually, I don't think about that from one day to another, unless somebody makes it an issue. That's not who I am. So the point about Windrush was that I wanted to say, first of all, we are people in our own right with our own narrative.
白人会怎么想或怎么做来写黑人社区。几乎没有人谈论我们实际上是谁。也许这是一种傲慢，或者更可能是因为我在加勒比海长大，来自一个对自己有很强认同感的大家庭。我只是厌倦了被当作好像我每天早上醒来都在想，我的白人邻居会怎么看我？实际上，我并没有一天到晚想那个，除非有人把它变成一个问题。那不是我。所以关于“疾风号”的重点是，我想说，首先，我们是拥有自己叙事的独立个体。
And some of that narrative has nothing to do with how you guys treat us. Listen to us, look at us and look at us rather than as instruments of your rage or admiration for our creativity or whatever it is. Just look at us for what we think about ourselves. So for example, just a very small example, if you look at all the journalism or television and so on about Caribbean people, even now, the one thing that almost never figures is the one thing that we all generally have in common that is very powerful in our world, the church. We go to church on Sundays, you know, more than half of us, as opposed to one tenthtenth of the population as a whole.
其中一些叙事与你们如何对待我们无关。听听我们，看看我们，而不是把我们当作你们愤怒的工具，或者对我们创造力的钦佩，或者其他什么。只是看看我们自己是怎么想的。所以，举个非常小的例子，如果你看看所有关于加勒比人的新闻或电视等等，即使是现在，几乎从未出现的一件事是我们所有人通常共有的、在我们世界中非常有力量的一件事：教会。我们周日去教堂，你知道，我们中超过一半的人，而整个人口中只有十分之一。
But you never see that. And that's a time when actually, by and large, we are outside what they call the white gaze. And that's who we really are. But nobody's interested in that. Well, you have shocking stories about the one black woman going to the Anglican church and being told not to come back.
但你从来没见过。那是我们实际上很大程度上处于所谓的“白人凝视”之外的时候。那才是真正的我们。但没人对那个感兴趣。好吧，你有关于那个去圣公会教堂被告知不要再来的黑人妇女的令人震惊的故事。
I was appalled by that. I had no idea. Of course. I was appalled by that. I had no idea. Of course. I mean, terrible stories. Trevor, just one last question, just on the thing of why Windrush has been in the news so recently, the kind of the scandal about people not having their identity papers and so on and being denied citizenship. You cite in this context, a very, very interesting interview that Sajid Javid who was community secretary at the time went on to become home secretary in the wake of Amber Rudd who was
我对此感到震惊。我不知道。当然。我对此感到震惊。我不知道。当然。我的意思是，可怕的故事。特雷弗，最后一个问题，关于为什么“疾风号”最近出现在新闻中，关于人们没有身份证明文件等等而被拒绝公民身份的丑闻。你在这种背景下引用了萨吉德·贾维德（Sajid Javid）的一次非常、非常有趣的采访，他当时是社区大臣，后来在安珀·拉德（Amber Rudd）之后成为了内政大臣，安珀·拉德是
home secretary resigning over the Windrush scandal he said about the whole scandal that my parents came to this country just like the Windrush generation when I heard about the Windrush issue I thought that could be my mum it could be my dad it could be my uncle it could be me and you write about this and I think this is just the last point I want to dwell on the show, that ownership of the legend had begun to escape the grasp of the Caribbean. It was beginning to characterise a broader and diverse group of British citizens. I mean, do you think that that is the future of the role of the Windrush as a myth? And I use myth not in a pejorative sense, in a positive sense, that perhaps in the long run, the Windrush will stand as a moment in history that people like
因“疾风号”丑闻而辞职的内政大臣。他谈到整个丑闻时说，我的父母来到这个国家，就像“疾风号”一代一样。当我听到“疾风号”问题时，我想那可能是我的妈妈，可能是我的爸爸，可能是我的叔叔，可能是我的我。你写了这件事，我认为这是我想在节目中停留的最后一点，即对这个传说的所有权已经开始逃脱加勒比人的掌握。它开始表征一个更广泛和多样化的英国公民群体。我的意思是，你认为这就是“疾风号”作为神话的角色未来吗？我使用神话不是贬义，而是积极的意义，也许从长远来看，“疾风号”将作为一个历史时刻存在，人们像
Sajid Javid can lay claim to, and maybe Poles and all kinds of people who've come. I hope not. Right, because I was wondering how you felt about that. I hope not, because I think they have their own stories. I'm waiting for somebody to tell the Sajid Javid story, which is very different to mine, but it's very important. Do you think it lacks the kind of what the Windrush has? It has the iconic image of people coming off a ship. I mean that story. And it's a particular story, which, for example, will have its own iconic image, which is East African nations arriving by plane, having been persecuted by black Africans. Whole different story, but a really important story, which is yet to be told. But actually, and here's the important thing.
萨吉德·贾维德可以声称拥有它，也许还有波兰人和所有来过这里的人。我希望不是。对，因为我想知道你是怎么想的。我希望不是，因为我认为他们有自己的故事。我正在等待有人讲述萨吉德·贾维德的故事，这与我的故事非常不同，但非常重要。你认为它缺乏“疾风号”所拥有的那种东西吗？它有人们下船的标志性形象。我的意思是那个故事。这是一个特定的故事，例如，它将有自己的标志性形象，即东非国家的人乘飞机抵达，受到黑人非洲人的迫害。完全不同的故事，但一个非常重要的故事，还有待讲述。但实际上，这里是重要的一点。
I don't want to miss Dominic's earlier point, but let me come back to that. The important thing is Rishi Sunak is who he is and does what he does, I think, largely because of who his family was. When he produces policies which are to promote numeracy, studiousness, high levels of education, self-discipline. Where's that coming from? It's coming from the traditions with which he has been brought up. He hasn't become that kind of conservative for no reason at all. It is because these are the values that he believes in. And by the way, we're going to see some very serious implications of this. So for example, for that group of people, social care, which is our biggest issue as a country, is baffling because for them, putting your parents in the hands of strangers in homes somewhere isn't just expensive, it's immoral. And they are puzzled by the dilemma? I bet you at some point, Sunak will want to ask that question if he remains prime minister. The point I'm really making is all of these different groups have their own origins stories, which are interesting, but also they're significant because they will have an
我不想错过多米尼克之前的观点，但让我回到那个。重要的一点是，里希·苏纳克（Rishi Sunak）之所以是他，做他所做的事，我认为很大程度上是因为他的家庭。当他制定促进算术、勤奋、高水平教育、自律的政策时。这来自哪里？它来自他从小接受的传统。他并不是无缘无故地成为那种保守派。这是因为这些是他所信仰的价值观。顺便说一句，我们将看到这带来一些非常严重的后果。例如，对于那群人来说，社会护理，这是我们作为一个国家最大的问题，是令人困惑的，因为对他们来说，把你的父母交给某个地方养老院的陌生人不仅昂贵，而且是不道德的。他们对这个困境感到困惑吗？我敢打赌，如果苏纳克继续担任首相，他会在某个时候想问这个问题。我真正想说的是，所有这些不同的群体都有他们自己的起源故事，这些故事很有趣，但它们也很重要，因为它们会
impact on the way the whole country works. And if we say Windrush is the template for everybody else, we're doing what people always do, and which is why I'm banging about it, which is to say everybody who's not white is basically sort of the same. And the only reason they're basically sort of the same is because the story is about white people, not about them. We're defining them entirely in terms of how they're treated and their relationship to white people. My point on your point, Dominic, about Windrush, essentially what people say is, oh, don't get too fussed about Windrush. Don't get too fussed about this particular thing because there were always black people and we should recognize that. And if we don't recognize it, that's the explanation for why people are racist.
对整个国家的运作方式产生影响。如果我们说“疾风号”是其他所有人的模板，我们就是在做人们总是做的事情，这也是我一直在强调的原因，那就是说所有非白人基本上都是一样的。他们基本上是一样的唯一原因是故事是关于白人的，而不是关于他们的。我们完全根据他们如何被对待以及他们与白人的关系来定义他们。多米尼克，关于你提到的“疾风号”，本质上人们说的是，哦，不要对“疾风号”太小题大做。不要对这件特定的事情太小题大做，因为一直有黑人，我们应该认识到这一点。如果我们不认识到这一点，这就是人们种族主义的解释。
I think this is all nonsense. Of course, there were people who were not white in this country. But it's just silly to say there was a servant that somebody brought from India, and there was a slave that somebody might have brought from West Africa, and that that became a significant issue. I mean, the point is, there weren't a million of those people who were living next to peasants in Nottingham or miners in Cornwall. We're in a whole different world. I mean, the reason I'm getting worked up about it, I find it so disrespectful that we are constantly treated as symbols for something else, as pawns in an argument about somebody else. Instead of, as sociologists and historians do with everybody else, gather the evidence, look at who these people are, understand what they did and why they did it, and work out what that means for the society as a whole. They're always coming to us as though we're simply a reason to tell somebody else's story. Well, Trevor, your book Windrush, 75 Years of Modern
我认为这全是胡说八道。当然，这个国家有非白人。但说有人从印度带了一个仆人，有人可能从西非带了一个奴隶，这成为一个重要问题，这太愚蠢了。我的意思是，重点是，并没有一百万这样的人住在诺丁汉的农民或康沃尔的矿工旁边。我们处于一个完全不同的世界。我的意思是，我对此感到激动的原因是，我发现我们不断被当作其他东西的象征，作为关于别人的争论中的棋子，这太不尊重人了。而不是像社会学家和历史学家对待其他人那样，收集证据，看看这些人是谁，了解他们做了什么以及为什么这样做，并弄清楚这对整个社会意味着什么。他们总是来找我们，好像我们仅仅是一个讲述别人故事的理由。好吧，特雷弗，你的书《疾风号：现代英国的75年》
Britain is a brilliant corrective to all that. Absolutely wonderful account, both of Windrush and of, as the subtitle suggests, the 75 years that have followed, written by you and by your brother, Mike. Absolutely wonderful. Thanks so much for coming on and joining us. And thank you so much for listening to us. Great pleasure. Thank you so much for inviting me. See you next time. Goodbye.
是对这一切的一个精彩纠正。绝对精彩的叙述，既关于“疾风号”，也关于副标题所暗示的随后的75年，由你和你的兄弟迈克撰写。绝对精彩。非常感谢你来参加我们的节目。也非常感谢你们的收听。非常荣幸。非常感谢你的邀请。下次见。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。